Another strategy you can take is to create clear boundaries for your time off.
Instead of saying, "I'm out of the office. Feel free to Slack me whenever."
Say, "I'll be offline. Call me only if it's urgent."
To uphold these personal goals, work together as a team.
Set team goals for personal time.
Do it publicly, collect data and hold each other accountable.
These goals could sound like, "I will not check email between 6:00 and 8:00 p.m."
"I will have dinner with my family four nights a week"...
...or "I will go for a jog midday."
Check in on your team's progress and see how everyone's doing.
If you or your teammates are unsuccessful,...
...work together to help accomplish personal goals.
Lastly, you can negotiate for more time...
...to prevent work from creeping in to your personal life.
In business school, I teach students to negotiate for salary,...
...but realize I spoke almost nothing about negotiating for more time.
What does this look like in practice?
You can ask for more time on adjustable deadlines at work.
If your client asks for a deliverable Monday morning,...
...ask for an extension until Tuesday afternoon...
...so you don't find yourself working on your well-deserved weekend.
And don't worry too much about reputation.
Quality truly is the metric that matters most.
In my data, employees who proactively asked for more time...
...reported lower levels of stress and burnout...
...and were seen as more committed and professional by their colleagues.